[Ukraїner
Національні спільноти]
І буде краса.
[німецькою] Зроби, будь ласка, три кави,
а я візьму млинці.
[німецькою] Амір, йди пити каву та какао.
Хочеш? Сідай.
[німецькою] Ти хочеш щось?
[німецькою] Давай вип'ємо какао
та поїмо млинців. Ти хочеш?
[німецькою] Ні? Ти хочеш ще спати?
[німецькою] Поцілуй маму.
[німецькою] Поцілуночок. Йди ще спати.
[німецькою] Подай, будь ласка, ложку.
Ми завжди снідаємо разом.
[німецькою] Ми завжди снідаємо разом.
Традиція така німецька — готувати «фанки»,
німецькою — «Fanken».
Вони завжди готуються вранці,
щоб на сніданок вони були свіжі і пухкі.
[Юлія Тайпс
Очільниця ГО «Німецька молодь Закарпаття»]
Я вважаю, що однозначно потрібно
добре знати українську мову.
Вона є частинкою нашої душі
і взагалі нашої національності.
Свою дитину я намагаюся виховувати
у білінгвальному середовищі.
[німецькою] Амір, ходи поцілуймося.
Мама вже йде.
[німецькою] Давай поцілунок.
[німецькою] Мама повернеться о шостій.
[німецькою] Гаразд. Бувайте!
[Мукачево,
Закарпаття]
Етнічних німців в Україні є близько 33 тисячі.
На Закарпатті є 3-4 тисячі представників
німецької національності.
Етнічні німці на Закарпатті опинилися трохи інакше, ніж ті, що живуть в іншій частині України.
Нас завжди називали німцями,
яких привела Марія-Терезія.
Оскільки Закарпаття довгий час було
в складі Австро-Угорської імперії,
тому велика частина німців і австрійців прийшли
до нас [на Закарпаття] саме в цей час.
Закарпаття — це єдиний регіон,
який добре зберіг німецьку мову.
Тобто у нас є села, де розмовляють німецькою,
священники, які служать німецькою,
сім'ї, де говорять німецькою.
В порівнянні з іншими регіонами України,
то там цього, на жаль, не збереглося.
У 2016 році я стала членкинею
Ради німців України від Закарпаття.
Кожне поселення, де компактно
проживали етнічні німці,
має кілька людей німецької національності,
які займаються там цим рухом.
В наших планах є, щоб у кожному районі,
де проживають компактно німці,
була молода людина,
яка займалася б цим рухом.
[німецькою] Привіт, я вже тут.
Ми намагаємося передати людям мову,
навчити їх німецької мови.
Ми допомагаємо їм дізнатися про їхню сім'ю,
звідки вони походять.
Ми намагаємося їм розповісти, звідки
походять німці на Закарпатті, коли вони прибули,
як їх розселяли, що вони робили,
ким вони були  і так далі.
Ми стараємося, щоб це не забулося і щоб кожна сім'я, яка вважає себе етнічними німцями,
володіли цією інформацією
і могли розповісти звідки вони походять.
— [німецькою] Доброго ранку.
— [німецькою] Та вже доброго дня.
[німецькою] Ви вже забули.
Завжди об 11 годині, а ви «доброго ранку».
[відповідає німецькою нерозбірливо]
[німецькою] Ми виконаємо інтерактивну вправу.
[німецькою] Вправа перед вами.
Вправа перед вами.
Таня, перше речення. Таня, ви з нами?
[німецькою] Йому подобається
розмовляти німецькою.
[німецькою] Ні. Як?
— [німецькою] Може?
— [німецькою] Може.
Добре, йдемо далі... Тиберій.
[німецькою]  Клаудія любить гамбургери.
Так... Любить наша Клаудія гамбургери...
[німецькою] Анна, далі.
Певний час було заборонено говорити про це,
і ніхто не хвалився, що він німець.
В мене була ситуація в школі, я ще вчилася,
і до нас прийшов новий вчитель і сказав:
«Ой, я не можу вичитати, що це у вас за прізвище?»
І діти почали: «А, та вона фашистка».
Спочатку я була дуже обережна до цього, але
згодом зрозуміла, що про це треба говорити і знати.
І треба перебирати інформацію
від людей вже поважного віку.
Це, зазвичай, люди старші за 80 і за 90 років.
Поки вони живі, треба цю інформацію черпати,
бо далі я не знаю, чи моя дитина
буде цікавитися цим
і чи захоче він знати своє походження і коріння.
[Свалява,
Закарпаття]
[говорять німецькою]
Габріел Карлович, я тобі несу ось.
І буде краса,
Габріель Карлович.
Посередині столик.
Вони тут, можна сказати,
проживали все своє життя.
[Володимир Цанько
Керівник ансамблю «Швалбах»]
Вони [німці] не опинилися тут, вони тут жили.
Але одна з таких хвиль —  це було прибуття їх
із графом Шенборном, зокрема на Свалявщину.
— Це остання вже.
— Так, це одна з хвиль.
Це було в кінці XVIII - на початку ХІХ століття.
[Габріел Кметі
Учасник ансамблю «Швалбах»]
Спочатку він приїхав з декількома лісорозробниками,
а потім вони запросили
інших працівників із Німеччини.
Вони приїхали й оселилися.
Це вони заселили ці села німецькі.
Свалява — більше місто, то тут уже сконцентрувалася інтелігенція.
Школа була німецька, хор німецький,
спеціалісти були німецькі.
Працювала недалеко від Сваляви
в селі Драчино, це зараз Свалява...
Працювала там німецька фірма
«Латориця».
Мої предки з Баварії прийшли
приблизно 150 років тому.
Прапрадід прийшов як лісорозробник...
Приблизно 100 років тому він відкрив
в Драчино [Dorndorf],
перший від Сваляви в сторону Мукачева, деревообробну фабрику.
Це була його власність — фабрика.
Радянська влада від нього її забрала в 1945 році, націоналізувала.
А він був такий, по-нашому кажучи,
дуже майстровитий,
і він на потоці власними руками зробив такий
станок-млин — гатер, як кажуть по-нашому,
що робив шинглі, тобто дерев'яні дощечки
для покриття дахів.
На потоці сам зробив своїми руками.
І через тиждень радянська влада
знову в нього те забрала.
[Сміється]
І загнала його в Сибір.
Моя мама дуже любила пісні співати.
Зі старшими поколіннями, зі своїми подругами,
які тут проживали,
тітка моя і ще багато хто,
вони збиралися і часто співали німецькі пісні.
Мене це, як дитину...
Я завжди був біля них і співав з ними.
І я відкрив кафе-бар у Сваляві.
І нам стало трошки нудно...
Ми спробували виконати, зібралися...
Декілька активістів, які мали німецьке коріння.
І ми всі музиканти!
І вирішили щось спробувати пограти...
Але зародилася ідея, що так діло не піде,
потрібно заснувати організацію,
щоб відновити культуру і зберегти традиції.
Вирішили заснувати організацію
«Німецька громада».
Ми серйозно взялися і організували колектив
на базі цього товариства,
естрадно-фольклорний колектив «Швалбах».
♪ [співають німецьку пісню] ♪
Спочатку, коли ми зорганізувалися,
то якийсь період ми мали, що співати,
як каже Володимир Васильович, сумні пісні,
як «Пити суху воду» і подібні.
[наспівує німецьку пісню]
Вони нагадували нашим предкам,
котрі були в [концентраційних] таборах або
котрі сумували за Батьківщиною,
зокрема  і за Німеччиною,
звідки вони приїхали,
вони ж сумували теж за нею.
Вони приїхали у незвіданий,
невідомий для них край.
І вони співали більш сумні пісні,
котрі навіювали їм, нагадували Батьківщину.
Ми на фестивалях можемо виконати і таку пісню,
але зазвичай люди хочуть чути запальні пісні.
Тому виникла потреба не тільки у тих піснях,
які ми знаємо,
а ще й записати більш веселі слова
і вивчити ті пісні.
І пов'язано ще трохи з тим, що на фестивалях,
де ми раніше слухали...
То дійсно — хочеться плакати,
бо люди співають сумні пісні...
Ну, який це фестиваль?
Хотілося додати барв, такої родзинки,
щоб було весело і приємно прийти на фестиваль,
і щоб люди аплодували.
♪ [співають німецьку пісню] ♪
Наші села, колись це були німецькі осередки...
Для них взагалі німецька мова була перша і рідна.
То для них було природно, вони тяжко говорили українською, закарпатським діалектом.
Ми фактично говоримо українською, на діалекті,
а німецькою — лиш коли бачимося.
Мене познайомили із німецькою фірмою,
яка займається вихованням молоді
із неблагонадійних німецьких сімей.
Там, де в сім'ї є непорядок великий, відбирають
дітей, щоб вони не потрапили у колонію.
Щоб ці діти виростали, бачили іншу культуру
і не опинилися на вулиці.
Приїжджає комісія з Німеччини —
вони дивляться на сім'ю, на побут і будинок.
Психологи дивляться і розмовляють.
Ну і так я потрапив у цей проєкт.
Останній в мене страшний хуліган,
його все місто знало.
Він Ніклас, а по-нашому він — Микола.
Брався співати, навіть ми його десь записали,
коли приїжджала комісія з Німеччини дивитися.
То ми його ставили в колектив...
Він досконало вивчив українську мову,
діалект закарпатський.
Вони швидко вивчають українську мову.
Це ж діти, розумієте...
Вийшов тричі на вулицю, поспілкувався з бабусею,
з дружиною, із внучкою, моїм сином, і все!
Вони переходять дуже швидко на українську мову.
[Барбово,
Закарпаття]
[німецькою] Слава Ісу! Нарешті я тут!
— [німецькою] Так пізно.
— [німецькою] Та ні, не пізно.
— [німецькою] Так гарно пахне.
— [німецькою] Так, гарно, але трохи волого.
Це стандартні печі, я їх привіз з Австрії.
Це ще було в далекому 1996 році.
У 1996 році я їх привіз, а з 1998 року
функціонує пекарня.
У мене був друг в Австрії і він мав млин.
Він знав усі пекарні.
Каже: «Добра справа буде для тебе».
Він був тут у нас. Колгоспи тоді в нас
вже помирали, роботи не було.
[Йосип Калой
Власник пекарні]
Я за спеціальністю — ветлікар.
Він мене так вмовив і запропонував
свою допомогу із печами.
Він знайшов мені ці печі,
я мав їх привезти і тут встановити.
Я трошки дививися їхню технологію,
вона нам зовсім не підійшла.
Вони такий хліб не печуть.
Вони печуть все з різними приправами.
Дуже подібна пекарня є тут ще в іншому селі.
Ми там з жінкою 2 години повчилися і почали...
Спочатку була жінка, одна пекарка і я.
То я возив [хліб], сигналив і люди виходили.
Тепер маємо 6 пекарів, 2 водіїв, ну і я зі жінкою.
Ми із жінкою — пенсіонери, але працюємо.
Знаєте, мене постійно це питають.
Мені здається, я щодня чую це запитання,
коли хтось приходить у центр.
«Ну що ви тут робите? А ви підіть...»
Я завжди кажу, що мені тут добре.
Як би важко не було, в будь-якому випадку,
тут я почуваюся комфортно, вдома.
Тут я можу набагато більше принести
користі іншим і собі зокрема
Тому що тут я — Тайпс Юлія,
яку знають і поважають.
А туди я піду і повинна почати все з нуля.
Як тут, так і там потрібно працювати,
дуже багато працювати!
Як тут, так і там потрібно дотримуватися
законів, звичаїв, традицій і так далі...
В мене є мрія, щоб молоді етнічні німці
не їхали до Німеччини, а залишалися в Україні.
Я проживала в Німеччині довгий час,
я працювала, стажувалася, вчилася.
Але мене завжди тягне додому.
Мене всі питають: «Та що ти тут робиш?
Їдь вже тут туди, там для тебе буде
стільки можливостей!»
Ні, в мене тут багато можливостей.
Тут навіть земля допомагає...
Тому ось така у мене мрія...
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Режисерка монтажу
Ліза Литвиненко]
[Оператори
Макс Салій(Завалля), Сергій Розов]
[Субтитрувальниці
Юлія Литвиненко, Валерія Діденко]
[Ukraїner
Національні спільноти]
[USAID
Серія створена за підтримки
Агенства США з міжнародного розвитку (USAID)]